bonjour fabrice frattini merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment est-ce que vous accueillez les
annonces des manuels macron à
valenciennes aujourd'hui les enseignants
donc le professions exposées selon ses
mots qui devrait être vaccinée me fin
juin fin avril satisfaction parce qu'un
horizon qui est fixé ou bien déception
parce que l'attenté est trop longue
oui bonjour donc déjà nous avons cru au
mois de mars que nous serions vacciner
il y avait une annonce qui était cette
fois ci d'avoir annoncé par monsieur
blanc caire derrière refusé par monsieur
macron donc cette nouvelle annonce si
possible si jamais il ya des doses nous
n'y croyons qu'à moitié voire pas du
tout pour certaines sommes assez
désabusé je vous cache pas que
professions exposées nous le savons que
nous sommes exposés nous savons que les
familles sont exposés les familles de
nos élèves mais sans que nos élèves sont
exposés pourtant le seul protocole ray
sanitaires que nous avons fait d'ouvrir
les fenêtres
cet hiver nous avons fait court avec des
- 4 - 5° avec les fenêtres ouvertes sans
aucun purificateurs d'air
sans capteur de co2 donc voilà donc
limousin nous accueillons vraiment
froidement ces annonces et nous
attendons de voir
et autant vous dire que dans les salles
de professeurs ces annonces landu croit
qu'à moitié
il ya une condition sinequanone ont
également par rapport à cette annonce
lorsque le nombre de vaccins disponibles
aura augmenté à ce propos est ce que
vous êtes confiant pessimisme d'un côté
on sait qu'il ya des retards de
livraison de l'autre côté il ya terrible
tirs bretons de commissaire européen qui
dit que le lieu n'a pas besoin par
exemple de vàd de vaccins spots nick v
donc comme pour tout nous avons eu le
problème des masques problème des tests
nous envient des différents problèmes
logistiques donc moi je vous cache pas
avec mes collègues et d'un banc syndical
nous sommes vraiment pessimiste
nous verrons nous verrons ça mais nous
avons pris la mesure d'ailleurs moi dans
mon laissez nous sommes en l'action
aujourd'hui par rapport aux allègements
de protocole sanitaire dans notre
établissement vous alors nous avons
évoqué le fait d'être en grève nous
avons préféré faire cours dans la cour
parce que nous sommes toujours enfermés
dans nos classes sans aucune protection
supplémentaire donc monsieur castex nous
a dit qu'en extérieur nous ne craignons
pas grand chose beaucoup moins en tout
cas qu'en extérieur
donc nous avons décidé aujourd'hui de
faire cours dans la course nous avons
pris nos élèves en extérieur
heureusement la météo s'y prêter cet
hiver nous aurions voulu le faire n'ont
pas pu le faire donc oui c'est compliqué
en ce moment pour les enseignants nous
sommes au bout du rouleau
il ya beaucoup de collègues qui sont en
train de traquer des élèves également
c'est très compliqué et professions
exposées nous aurions voulu être écoutée
dès leur rentrée de septembre pour que
nous n'avions pas dans une situation
comme aujourd'hui vous it ont fait court
dans la course a fait penser 1
au nouveau mantra du gouvernement à
freiner sans enfermer
on a beaucoup parlé de fermer ou pas les
écoles avant l'annoncé jeudi par jean
castex de ce confinement troisième
génération finalement les écoles restent
ouvertes emmanuel macron sambi tenir
comment ça se passe concrètement dans
vos établissements scolaires donc là on
l'a bien compris vous faites court
dehors pour vous faire entendre
mais est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de cadres
qu'ovide 19 parmi les enseignants parmi
les élèves parce que les tests
salivaires suffisait ce que les
protocoles sanitaires sont respectés
alors protocole a été respecté ça
toujours été si possible nous ne pouvons
pas réellement les faire respecter est
que ce soit au niveau du port du masque
dans les couloirs en extérieur et c'est
bien sûr que
en fait j'ai nombre de cas de provident
sont en train d'exploser dans notre
établissement
jusqu'à présent nous étions assez
protégé nous étions dans un système
hybride une semaine une semaine pour
casser les chaînes de contamination un
élève qui est contaminée à la semaine
qui doit la maison de contamines
personnes dans l'établissement depuis
quelques jours le rectorat nous impose
de passer à deux jours présentiel deux
jours à la maison donc nous craignons
encore plus pour les contaminations
parce que c'est vraiment en train
d'exploser dans l'établissement il y a
eu des tests n'ont pas sali ferme et
antigénique pour une moitié des élèves
du lycée à la sortie des vacances
aucun test n'a été positif
et depuis depuis quelques jours les
textes et les tests positifs explose
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des clusters
monza la nation au sein des
établissements scolaires
un sondage ifop réalisé entre le 25
février et le 8 mars dernier montre que
75 % des directeurs et directrices
d'école s'épuise en france 26% des
personnes interrogées pensent à quitter
leurs fonctions
c'est vraiment le trop plein au sein
au sein des établissements scolaires oui
exactement vous êtes fait le mot nous en
parlions entre collègues il n'y a pas un
seul enseignant qui dors bien la nuit
depuis septembre nous sommes nous nous
sommes toujours face à notre conscience
est-ce qu'on crée des clusters dans nos
classes est ce qu'on va faire en sorte
que les élèves verra ramène le virus
chez eux
est-ce qu'on fait des erreurs notre site
notre application pédagogique
l'état n'a pas investi dans l'éducation
est-ce que des bâtiments ont été
réquisitionnés est ce qu'il ya en bauges
d'enseignants au contraire il ya 1800
suppressions de postes à la rentrée donc
tout repose sur nos épaules sur le fait
de prendre des heures sup à la rentrée
ne pouvons pas les ne pouvons pas les
prendre ces heures sup c'est impossible
donc oui il ya un épuisement total de la
part des équipes vraiment dit c'est
vraiment difficile des élèves aussi sont
fatigués 1 c'est pas facile pour eux
d'être à moitié à l'école et bien moitié
en présentiel
qu'est ce que vous dénoncez essentiel
qu'est ce que vous dénoncez concrètement
que les écoles soient ouvertes pendant
ce confinement ou bien les politiques de
d'ouverture justement de ces écoles
par rapport donc au fait que comme vous
dites des lieux n'ont pas été
réquisitionnée comme cela parce qu'on
sait que si les écoles ferment ça veut
dire que les enfants ne sont pas gardés
donc les parents ne peuvent pas
travailler donc il ya un gros souci au
niveau de l'économie qui va continuer à
souffrir dans quelle solution pour vous
pour qu'il y ait pas de perdant
exactement nous nous voulons d'ailleurs
le confinement l'année dernière a
complètement reposer sur les sur les
enseignants il ya personne qui nous a
guidés 1
il n'ya pas d'inspecteurs qui nous a dit
comment faire pour que nos élèves etc
nous n'avons touché aucune prime de 100
tués au travail à la maison et nous
avons perdu le contact d'une certaine
façon que nos élèves nous voulons pas
revivre ça il missionne pour l'ouverture
des établissements scolaires mais pas
n'importe comment avec une vraie
protection des enseignants vaccination
pour les enseignants il est vrai une
vraie protection des élèves ça veut dire
des salles avec des purificateurs d'air
avec des capteurs de co2 pour qu'on
sache quand c'est ce qu'il faut aérer ou
non avec embauches massives
d'enseignants réquisition de bâtiments
il y a 6 l'état voulant investir mettre
de l'argent on pourrait le faire il n'y
a pas un seul centime d'euro qui a été
mis par le ministère de monsieur lancar
merci fabrice fatin et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de mathématiques et
représentant syndical cgt au lycée
gutenberg de créteil en région
parisienne